surtout ne touchez à rien ne bougeait
pas rester avec
et mais je crois que les téléphones dans
les collèges sont interdits à la rentrée
na waie le mini ducation indique qu'il
s'agit de protéger les enfants protégés
ça veut dire que les écrans et efron
quoi sont dangereux pour notre santé
moi j'ai entendu que c'était mauvais
pour les yeux il faut peut-être qu'on
prenne contact avec un opticien
j'ai lu aussi que la dépendance aux jeux
vidéo est maintenant considérée comme
une maladie mais qui peut nous parler de
la dépendance ou de téléphone au réseau
puis aux jeux vidéo peut-être un médecin
plutôt un psychologue
bon bah c'est parti pour le 7ème
reportage
j'ai droit de jouer à la console que le
week end et les vacances que le week end
et les vacances et le mercredi après
midi si j'ai fini mes devoirs un peu
autant que je me mets pas plus de deux
heures et demie maximum pour mon
téléphone ou tablette
j'ai le droit de jouer toute la semaine
mon téléphone je ne joue pas souvent je
plus sur les réseaux sociaux qui voulait
que les sourires en plastique les
followers fait erreur vous savez juste
la cote
clairement pour ce tournage là l'équipe
de reporters se sont carrément concernés
par le sujet première étape au collège
des clairs soleils rentrée l'un des
premiers de la région à avoir banni
l'usagé du portable dans l'enceinte de
l'établissement c'est est en 2009
c'était une décision de ses chefs
d'établissement de soumettre une
interdiction de l usage du téléphone
portable
il ne supportait pas le fait que les
élèves de plus en plus écoutent de la
musique ça vaille couloir dans la cour
où se prennent en photo
s'il ya quand même un problème de droit
à l'image quand même comme vous le devez
le savoir les infractions règlements
sont en réalité très peu nombreuses et
le numérique se cantonne ici à la
pédagogie
il s'agit en fait d'apprendre en
utilisant les outils de son époque
même si cela augmente encore le temps
d'exposition aux écrans
avec les risques qui vont avec est-ce
que vous avez mesurez vous à peu près à
quel temps vous passez sur les écrans en
moyenne chaque jour je passe environ 14
heures par semaine sur mon téléphone
ces douze heures par jour et j'étais
bien dans la moyenne nationale rend
compte que pour un enfant il passe entre
deux et trois heures devant des écrans
est-ce que regarder trop d'écran ça
modifie la vue des ados un écran de
téléphone portable ou tablette on tient
à peu près de 10 cm plus près qu'un
livre ses petits centimètres c'est pas
beaucoup comme ça mais en optique ça
c'est tout de suite beaucoup plus
important on sait que les hd écran avec
des distances très rapprochées peut
donner des mieux payés évolutive ché ché
chez les ados sans compter la fatigue
oculaire et l'excitation du à la lumière
bleue des écrans mais les effets les
plus négatifs sont ceux pointés par les
psychiatres et les psychologues
catastrophique pour les moins de 6 ans
mais tout aussi alarmant pour les ados
accrochés à leur téléphone ou leur
console quelqu'un qui passe trop de
temps sur un écran peut tout à fait je
dirais souffrir de confusion et donc du
coup ça crée des difficultés de
concentration et donc du coup ça fait
chuter les résultats scolaires par
exemple
c'est un des effets qui me paraît les
plus probants les plus négatifs et qui
font peur aux parents après 12 ans
l'écran peut avoir sa place dans la vie
de l'adolescent mais avec des garde-fous
il faut il faut l'accompagner pour
pouvoir choisir sur le net sur les
réseaux sociaux parce que c'est
extrêmement dangereux il ya des règles
il faut jamais mettre d'image de soif
parce que toutes ces images là après
nous nous appartiennent plus du tout oui
deux fois oui
l'addiction aux écrans peut avoir des
conséquences graves et cette fois ci la
recommandation ne vient pas des adultes
mais de nos apprentis reporters e mail
m